[Music]
foreign
ly I very much agree with Brian because
it is a Marketplace of ideas at least in
theory and as long as there are
equations and ideas and people who wish
to explore them the ideal of the
scientific Community is that we should
do exactly that and the problem is is
that that is not exactly how science
works and in particular this ignores the
entire political economy of science
which has to do with jobs claims public
relations and effectively diverting the
resources of the community which are
never particularly generous after the
Cold War era
towards string theory and it's not just
a question of let's say delivering
better pizzas but also slashing the
tires of the opposing pizza parlor and
so the real problem is is that we keep
talking about what we're comfortable
with which is
the nature of the ideas string theorists
often say that's not how science works
and I'm the concern about string theory
is that string theory works like no
other science and so the biggest
complaint that many of us have is that
string theory sets itself up as the
judges and referees who's winning who's
losing what's the best leading theory
and finding themselves virtuous in
almost all contests so it's like playing
a team verse of referees who may not
necessarily be better footballers but
tend to find that they always win the
game so let's save the time for debate
and let's get into it I think the
trouble with string theory is that there
isn't any connection with observations
I'm probably taking too strong of you
here but the Mythic I mean it's largely
driven by the mathematics as far as I
know which is in itself is not an
objection as far as I'm concerned a lot
of what I do is driven by the
mathematics but the trouble with
strength there is it's supposed to be a
theory of the way the world operates and
if the number of dimensions of space is
just wrong
I can't take it seriously and I can I
mean there are arguments why all these
extra dimensions are hidden and I don't
think those arguments are right either
so I'm just left in the position where I
don't the problem is not so much you
know how much mathematics or how much
physics or what we're not talking about
things which can be experimentally
tested anyway as far as I can see if you
could have a theory which had
predictions and these predictions could
be seen to be right or wrong that's what
I understand about physics but String
Theory seems to me driven largely by
certain ideas which
have importance in mathematics but sort
of irrelevant to the physics really as
far as I know there's places where
string theory has had an impact on
mathematics sure it has but it's not
physics as far as I can see so the main
problem I have with the strength there
is I don't think it's physics so
um I appreciate your remarks Roger
obviously I have a different perspective
on it one when it comes to the fact that
various formulations of string theory do
require extra dimensions that's of
course a long-standing program that
existed long before String Theory the
whole klutza Klein program dating back
to the early Decades of the 20th century
is one that considered the possibility
that a universe might actually have
extra Dimensions the issue of exciting
modes in the extra Dimensions is one
that I think we understand reasonably
well that the energy goes like one over
the putative size of the extra
Dimensions so if their size is
sufficiently small the energy that needs
to be focused and efficiently small
region to excite those modes is larger
than any energy that we have access to
but if we did have that energy we would
be able to excite those modes I have a
feeling that we're not going to be able
to settle that in in this discussion
here but I'm not concerned and in fact
moreover I've spent decades thinking
about those extra Dimensions so I think
it's actually a very fruitful part of
the theory as opposed to something that
is a detriment or something that is an
embarrassment it's a wonderful quality
of the theory in terms of whether string
theory is physics I would put forward
two points number one the whole reason
why we are interested in string theory
is that we believe the world is governed
at least in certain energy scales by the
general theory of relativity giving us
our theory of gravity we believe that on
sufficiently small scales quantum
mechanics shows its colors and we
believe there are Realms in which
general relativity and quantum mechanics
need to play together
and without a theory of quantum gravity
physics is at a loss for how to proceed
and so the value of string theory in
physics is that it gives us a quantum
theory of gravity that's why we're
interested in it and that's why it's
part of physics I agree fully that we
don't understand the theory well enough
yet to draw direct predictions for
things that we can go out and measure
that's why it is a theory very much a
theory in progress and how long will it
take to extract those kinds of
predictions I don't know I wish we had
those predictions too because if we
could verify them great if we could
prove the theory wrong fantastic too